okay so welcome to the meeting of the
northeast leadership council's cabinet
it's the 4th of august
at 4 30 or just after
um
with me in the in the in the chamber is
council cupid and councillor kenyon
we have mrs sternberg mrs dethick
matt broughton alan maher and uh
tom scott from governance and then on
the screen we have catherine
and mark foster came to mark foster as
well
so first item is apologies for absence
have we received any
uh yes chair we've got receiver
apologies from councillor parkin
councillor powell and councillor renwick
brilliant thank you
uh and then the next item is declaration
of interest i don't think there are any
no
um
and then the next item is minutes to the
last meetings um held on both the 7th of
july on the 21st of july because we had
an extraordinary one
um i'm happy with them i'll happily move
them
okay that's second goodbye cancer cupid
all those in favor
okay that's carried
and then the next item is the council
plan
uh performance update
um and i'll hand over to cath just to
briefly talk us through that that's okay
okay uh thank you chair good afternoon
everyone uh so as as you know this is
the q1 performance report april to june
of the council plan targets
uh you'll know from the front uh from
the first page of the report there were
77 targets
left in the framework 49 of those are on
track at q1 27 of those have been
achieved previously and then there's one
today that there's a recommendation
around replacing that so i'll cover the
report generally and then i'll talk
about the uh the target that there's a
specific recommendation around
so
as you'd expected q1 everything's pretty
much um going okay which is good but
just a couple of things i wanted to draw
members attention to
so
under our economy obviously 10 targets
on track which is all good but just to
note the very positive update on eco 15
which is on page 17 of your report
regarding the
equities job fair that took place on the
12th of may very well attended and very
well received so the office has put a
lot of detail in on that update so i
just want to draw your attention to that
and then under our environment aim
just uh six targets on track and eight
have already been achieved uh just to
draw members attention to
um environment 13 and environment
14 targets both on page 21.
uh the first one is concerning the
issuing of fixed penalty notices for
litter and dog fouling so that's already
ahead of out turn at q1
uh the target was for nine and they've
already issued eleven fixed penalty
notices in q1
and num
target 14 is ought to do a litter picks
they plan to do three little picks in q1
and they've done four so it's just to
know those um
ahead of uh target out turns which is
very good under environment and then
lastly under the residence one
um
22 targets on track for already been
achieved just to note
under
target number 12 res 12 on page 23
really positive update about website
accessibility
and usability of the website with the
council having
an excellent rating for both
accessibility and user experience in q1
so obviously accessibility is really
important to do a lot of work generally
in this area across the council to
improve accessibility to services so
it's good that the website is achieving
high results there as well
and then for services uh 21 left
open targets and 11 are on track and
we've already achieved 10 of those
targets so
um that just gives you a general flavor
of
the targets council plan targets at q1
and then if i just move on to
environment number 17
uh which if you can recall um
the original target is all to do with
measuring percentage of cases of waste
crime where there's sufficient evidence
to prosecute so it was to do with the
environmental health officer the length
of time
for them to put the file together to
then pass on to legal for them to take
action obviously this is a very internal
focused target and the desire was to
have a more external focus target
so the recommendation or what's been put
forward around this target is
to deliver one high-profile print and
social media campaign per quarter
on an environmental health
enforcement topic with the aim of
influencing behavioural change and the
idea behind this target is it'll give
kenny sword and his team the ability to
include a lot more detail about what uh
environmental work they've been
undertaking what prosecutions they've
wanted they've undertaken how many fixed
penalty notices of issue so the idea is
that a lot of information will be
provided under this target
which encompasses more what the what
work is being done in that area
so that's the uh
the replacement target that's that's
coming forward today
um as you know i do go to audit scrutiny
before i bring the report to cabinet and
audi did ask me to pass on some comments
regarding this uh target
um they've got no particular issues with
the target as such but they would also
like an additional target
that evidence is more the
uh the influence of behavioral change so
this target includes that the revised
target but they
would like a target in addition which
evidence is that now obviously this is
the last year the current corporate plan
we will be building a new corporate plan
a new council plan at the end of this
year
so it may be that that comments brought
into
into consideration when we
think about specific targets under the
new council plan the
audit committee was also quite keen to
keep the existing target around the uh
prosecution part but once again
that is retained by environmental health
management it is part of their internal
management dashboard so they are keeping
a watch over the performance in that
area
but i obviously was tasked with
providing that feedback so i've given up
giving that feedback to cabinet and that
concludes the report from our
perspective chair
thanks very much kath um yeah i remember
we had some discussion around
env 17 at the previous meeting it did
feel a bit sort of
um
niche uh if you like and quite bean
counter-ish and actually i think the new
the the proposed new uh
target there is is far better in a lot
of ways it's more
outward-facing and also it's focusing on
on prevention really isn't it it's it's
it's about
sort of demonstrating um
the high profile sort of work that we
are doing around environmental
enforcement with the aim of trying to
stop people from doing some of the
things that need enforcing in the first
place so it it for me it's an all-round
better target obviously take on board
the comments of audit but i think
what's proposed there um is the right
thing and
and is easier to understand actually
what we're trying to achieve whereas the
original target it just it doesn't
really it doesn't really tell us a lot i
don't think personally um
thanks chet um yeah i agree i think that
from discussing this proposed uh new
target with with ken uh as the head of
environmental health um the the idea as
you mentioned cath was a bit to have
behind it in that sort of box regular
updates on
sort of what's been happening in terms
of prosecutions because any prosecutions
that we do do obviously
it's sad that we have to do them but it
is a good news story that we've been
able to catch people and deter them so
i'm uncomfortable that
what i think audit committee we're
asking for will be incorporated in this
new target because the information will
be added behind it and that that was the
conversations that i've had with with
ken so i'm quite comfortable with it um
for the same reasons you've outlined
chair so i'm happy to see how it goes
and as you say we can when we review the
plan in the next year we can sort of
incorporate any changes as necessary as
well
brilliant uh uh kensal kane
thank you chad yes more of a general
comment which is the performance reports
it's good for what it does but it does
always leave me a little bit frustrated
because what isn't captured is all the
things that weren't set up as targets
three years ago that we do which are
huge pieces of work you know leveling up
bids a new leisure center things like
that and somewhere along the way we've
got to find a way to capture
those things as well because otherwise
it's sort of
it's under representing the performance
of the council i always think that's a
shame
and one day we've got to find a way to
present the the extra things that get
added into offices workload as well as
the things that we anticipated so it's
just a general comment really but uh
yeah i'll leave it there thanks
yeah thanks cancer can you absolutely
agree i think um part of the desire
around updating the council plan
over the next few months is we'll
hopefully address that because i think
the performance targets are based on a
council plan that was written pre-coded
pre-town deal pre you know all of these
things that we know about that that have
happened since so it does feel like
we're working to a slightly out of date
now
um plan and i think that needs updating
as part of that
work really otherwise though it's a good
good report it all makes a good reading
we're doing doing well it seems on most
most of those uh kpis so i'm happy to
uh move the report
capture kenyan uh all those in favor
okay that's carried thanks very much
kath uh
for your team and all the work on that
uh and then the next paper then is the
mtfp
budget monitoring report for quarter one
um in the absence of councillor parking
i'm gonna hand over to jane datic to
talk through this one
thank you chain you're happy to do so
so the purpose of this report is to
update on the financial position to the
31st uh 31st of june 30th of june
um current forecast is to underspend by
122k but this is just quarter one
there's a long way to go yet
um main variances are highlighted at two
point two to two point five of the
report
bit of a mixed bag in quarter one if i'm
honest um pay budget savings make up a
good proportion of the underspend
and full details are in appendix 1 and
appendix 2 should you wish to
consider them in more detail
table 2 in the report shows that we've
achieved our efficiencies that were
needed for 22-23 we fully expected to
achieve those in quarter one the target
was very low this year at 111 000
and but more importantly to know are
some of the budget pressures that we've
started to identify detailed at 2.9 in
the report and we'll be giving those
careful considerations as we review the
budgets at the end of the next quarter
some of the pressures will be
capitalized some will come fund from
reserves but nonetheless the utilities
the fuel and the higher than expected
payroll are all going to put significant
pressures on the budget this year and in
the case of pay award future years
um in terms of the hra there are very
few issues of no very few variances so
i'll just point you to appendix 4 to
provide the quarter 3 position
and in terms of capital expenditure
appendix 5's got the scheme by scheme
details bit of slippage in the first
quarter which isn't overly unusual as
contracts get up and running one of the
bigger concerns we've got is the rising
cost of contracts that we're seeing
within the capital programme and that's
something we're going to have to pay
some close scrutiny to as we review the
budgets later on this year
finally appendix 6 has got the treasury
management activity for quarter 3 for
your information
i'm happy to take any questions and move
back to you for the recommendations
chair okay thanks jane any questions
uh kenneth canyon
yeah more of a general one uh well two
really um
obviously difficult times financially
for for all sorts of
organizations so i'm just wondering how
how are other councils getting on would
be one question i know we had any
feedback about their difficulties and
the second one is with the cost of
living
um if we only thought yeah about how
that might affect council tax income or
rent income for hra thanks
yeah both excellent questions um we
actually met i actually met with my
colleagues across derbyshire just
yesterday afternoon and we had that
roundtable discussion because we're all
very nervous about the impact on
utilities um
the utilities and the fuel is less of a
long-term pressure so we're all we're
all relatively comfortable that we've
either got surpluses within the year or
so reserves set aside that we can meet
them that they're maybe not going to be
long-term pressures the one that's
worrying most of us is the ongoing
impact of the pay award because of
course you'll know that we we have to
build the pay into the base so if pay is
going up i mean the national offers
averaging out about seven percent um
that's a significant growth to the
budget year on year um and we've all got
some concerns about that we've decided
as a group to
to lobby the treasury on that point um
and d look just to make them aware of
the impact on on us and we'll wait to
see whether that yields fruit in the in
the settlement before christmas but it
certainly is a major impact
the second question was remind me i've
got a memory like a sieve
yes not yet not as yet um we've not seen
any major issues on our rent collection
and council tax collection yet but
the real issues are yet to buy on the
utilities yes define when people are
going to have to make a choice so
something we've got on our radar and
something that we're going to have to
monitor very closely over the coming
months but i would almost certainly
expect it to impact on quarter 4
and i'll report back to you on that one
yeah
thank you
brilliant thanks very much for that any
other questions
no okay um i'm happy to um
to move the recommendations we have a
secondary
yeah can i keep it all those in favor
okay thank you that's carried
and the next item then on the agenda
i think is urgent items
it is urgent items of which there are
none so i'm happy to declare the meeting
close thanks very much for joining us
you